our following guests and I have a lot in
common we both appeared naked on the
cover of ESPN the magazine's body issue
his thighs measure 28 inches around both
of mine combined measure 28 inches
around he's known for his weight room
prowess he can power clean over 400
pounds I'm more of a clean and jerk guy
maybe we don't have anything in common
but we do have the same broadcasting
degree in communications
therefore we mailed it in in college
please welcome say Quan Barkley
[Applause]
police going down the road they're
saying hello to everybody say Quan how
are you yes you can rot in his old spice
hopefully you're not giving me a hint
there but it's good to see you again how
you doing how you feeling doing good
yeah you ever been fishing I've ever
been fishing like once when I was little
but not really big into it and you grew
up born in the Bronx good repentance man
you that were your Steeler fan no I was
a New York Jets fan you never changed
when you got there nah I feel like when
I got to Pennsylvania I don't want
everyone you love the Steelers the
Eagles or the Patriots so I ain't what I
might be like everyone else
so it's kind of stuck my dad's a judge
fan too so I kind of stuck with Jess do
you have posters on your wall uh no my
dad got like a tattoo but that's only
thing we had like he got a tattoo of the
Jets
yeah oh so it's serious no no yes it is
if he's a big Jets fan did you want to
get drafted by the Jets oh no I just
wanted to go New York kind of either one
that didn't sound too convincing because
it was Jets was number three yeah and
the Giants is number two and like if you
guys say anybody would you rather go
number two or number three and
everyone's gonna say probably too so
could you imagine how emotional your dad
would have been if he went to the Jets
the same thing though cuz I'm home like
I'm literally hour away from where my
parents live so I got the best of both
worlds no matter what who was your
running back your Curtis Martin I'm
gonna go meet him yeah I met him I did
like a little segment way before and I
played him in chess I started picking up
chess and uh he got the best of me let's
say that yeah because you know
physically you look like Barry Sanders a
little bit do you get that comparison on
coming out of college yeah I got that -
have you met Barry
yeah there's Barry's uh probably my
favorite player and football Barry made
it look pretty easy as a running better
definitely like there's certain guy I
don't know if there's somebody else that
you look at them and you go like Patrick
mahomes makes playing quarterback look
easy yeah yeah but is there another
running back where you go it's not as
easy as he's making a team
Christian McCaffrey he does I think he's
a dick he makes it look pretty easy this
is a competition between you two I
believe that every single one of us here
who's the best running back in football
um the best running back of football
obviously I was saved myself but outside
myself I will pick dare kind of he
finished his season amazing but I would
go with Chris McAfee was a the best
friend of that
could you imagine trying to tackle
Derrick Henry that's why I play often
have you made a tackle uh I miss the bad
type with this chickens Dallas glad that
never got won't you're not the only
giant who missed a tackle against the in
college actually my sophomore year I
played JV running back but I was I
started a little varsity so in a year
for sophomore and um I got like some
looks for defense but my first offer was
I got offered for running back by
Rutgers off my JV highlight film so if
it wasn't Penn State you were going to
Rutgers no I committed to Rutgers first
I like admit it I was going to Rutgers
and then James Franklin Penn State off
of me and kind of stole me what was it
just obviously coach Franklin all those
guys did amazing job but I don't know if
you guys ever been to a Penn State game
but if you go to I have been too happy
been a white owl and a hundred ten
thousand fans screaming I don't think it
get any better than that so kinda just a
tradition and there's just a history
there and actually being there and
seeing the games kind of just sold me so
like 15,000 people at Rutgers watching a
football game was not like I'm not gonna
some short but I don't think any I don't
think any uh haven't played down south
really so I can't speak on them but all
the places I've been
no one competes with Penn State we're
talking to shake one Berkeley of the
Giants
what was your welcome to the NFL moment
somebody hits you know I was I walked in
the locker room in my team it was Eli
Manning I said I was my welcome to NFL
so you see him and then yeah that was
I mean like I said with a Jets fan and
when the judge said make the playoff
which was often and the Giants were
saying we were root for the Giants my
family root for the Giants and so I
always root for Eli and you know I have
I can remember exactly where I was at
when they won both of super balls and so
when I like walked into the I guess to
say the locker room or it was a lunch
room actually and I saw Eli Manning I
was like oh I guess that was it but what
hit would be new talking about it
earlier who was on here JJ Watt we had
like a counter played to left
he beat the right tackle to the right
and still made a tackle as I was getting
the ball and kind of just like drove me
back and I was just like I just started
clapping like how do you deal with
injuries how do you deal with injuries
it's already game you know it's it's
it's gonna happen you know it depends
how severe they are but you want to come
back and help your team but you have to
be patient
yeah but it's also like it's it's a fine
line because sometimes it's are you
telling yourself you're not healthy or
you're actually not healthy and that's
why I said there's every every injury is
different and obviously I got hurt this
year but I felt like that I could've
came back even earlier than that but
obviously I didn't and I waited three or
four weeks but it was in my mind say I
think everyone's different when I got
hurt my mindset was out for four weeks
my first thing said how can I come back
tomorrow and the things I can do in the
rehab I can do and you know I can do a
treatment I was just my mindset and then
when you get injured in games you know
sometimes you know you just your
Adrenaline's going it's just your
adrenaline rushes at a high level and
you're just trying to do whatever you
can to go out there and win games that I
don't even bother you or you don't even
notice it - probably next morning how
did you pick your number I was 21 at
high school and then they they told me
at Penn State I would be 21 when I get
there I got the I was 26
one of my good friends who played for
the Detroit Lions Imani he was 21 I was
supposed to play special teams my
freshman year so we couldn't both be on
I suppose we keep returning I end up
being one too started running backs and
then an NFL I wouldn't consider changing
my number but when I got drafted I had
like the highest jersey so I guess and I
thought I was just stuck with 26 oh so
you didn't want to change I mean I
probably change at some point in my
career I think but I go back to 21 um
maybe 21 I liked 21 I like 24
maybe something in 30-some different you
graduated in communications two more
classes oh okay alright so what do you
want to do with that you want to do this
yeah all right let's go you ask you want
to you get two questions for me you've
got me in this last year what helped you
yeah if you needed help I was there fits
you know that final paper and you need
to interview big-time broadcast over my
accent and introduce you to Bob Costas
what's the what's the moment that you
realized that this is a passion of what
you want to do for your life I was 12
years old and I would read the Sports
Illustrated and I would cut out the
pictures before my dad got home so he
would pick up the Sports Illustrated and
all the pictures would be cut out
because they would be on my bedroom wall
I feel like a lot of athletes think that
you know just because we play sports and
I even had this mindset last year which
I was talking to you and I will be a
great answer not only for myself but for
young athletes a lot a fleets think that
once I don't the sport they could just
transition right to this because they
played it but what's the hardest part I
was transitioning to get into the level
that you're at well you got to decide if
you you know are you somebody who's
gonna teach the game when you do a game
Tony Romo can teach a game to you when
he does or are you gonna just be an
entertainer like what what kind of
analysts do you want to be but also when
you're you're doing it how much do you
know the game you play the game
sometimes you may not know the game
it's just reactionary to you can you
break down the defense for me
you know other positions and that I find
is really hard especially from a running
back position because you see the game
differently than a quarterback or a
tight end would or a middle linebacker
and quarterback to me or maybe a free
safety could see the game and be an
analyst and tell you everything that's
going on feels like those positions
because you're just lining up and you're
probably looking at there's a linebacker
here running backs or defensive ends so
you see the game in smaller picture you
got to see a big picture if you're gonna
be able to broadcast because that's the
fun part when you have somebody saying
look at the Mike linebacker he's
cheating right there
now we don't see it but you would see it
now what's that mean and then you tell
somebody that
yeah to be able to do that in real time
we do have your draft profile anyway
how's my questions it was good now
here's the thing when you ask a question
take out the front part of that athletes
transitioning just say what's the
hardest part for athlete get right to
your question okay
really quick it's like getting to the
hole quick you know unless your lady on
bail and you dance a little bit
I want you going straight ahead with
your questions alright thank you this is
your draft profile we had a hard time
finding negative things here but I want
you to read your this year draft this is
these are actual comments made about
shake one Barclay plays with
inconsistent leg drive to contact we're
working between the tackles what does
that mean
that when you get tackled I guess my
legs don't continue a turn so basically
I say it I get tackled easy any this is
accurate you can say oh yeah I'm see I'm
I'm big on you know being a self critic
okay if you want to involve your game
and I always say I want to be one of the
best to play I got to be my own critic
first you score exactly so this this
won't bother me okay I agree with that
no not that part we'll need to we'll
need to develop a more north/south
mindset as a pro I agree with that 100%
it's too cute with stutter steps in
juice on the first level and allowing
help to flow to the ball mm-hmm that's
an interesting
do you float a little bit mmm it depends
which were you looking for like at the
first level sometimes it worked for like
a lady on bail but a Derrick Henry
that's not his type of that's not as
tight but for me I don't view myself as
there's a one-dimensional type of back
so I feel I can do a little bit before
that okay so it depends on type of run
type of scheme I had this is a power
scheme is that the guys scheme is his
own scheme has about with focus drops as
a pass catcher and it's castrate radius
is limited I had 91 catches my work this
is something I would agree on a hundred
percent and this is like I said be
yourself critic inconsistent at
take-home blocks and pass bro pass throw
is something that you might want to use
that Old Spice I think you're starting
to get a little fired up there that's
something that agree with hundred cent
that be more consistent about a pass
blocker a lot of teams when you last
year I called a lot of passes a lot of
teams will blitz a running back or blitz
like a Christian McCaffrey no side big
guys
so either keep them in and to get them
to take away space from catching the
ball in space so that's a lot of things
things we do I mean I'm like going for
the quarterback most time they're just
trying to get a lick on you isn't a
wrecking ball at all can't be taken down
by the ankles I mean have I been angle
talk--i before I just we just point
these everyone everyone's been tagging
before my first year I had I broke the
most tackles I missed a couple games
this year and I'm pretty sure I was in
the NFL just so yeah who's coming into
the NFL yeah that'll make sense cuz I
mean I'm not too big on this but like I
guess PFF or whatever it's called like
profile company cuz yeah whatever is
called
my last year in college I broke the most
tackles so like that don't make no sense
and the final one doesn't run like a 233
pound back we're not talking Leonard
fournette
or Adrian Pearson as an inside brother
I don't I don't run like a 230 pound
back I think that's what makes me unique
I think that's why you could say you can
see similarities do a Barry Sanders or a
shady but when need be if it's if it's
that short down distance or I need to
finally get that that yard I can run
like a 230 pound back so yeah a lot I
love seeing stuff like this Drew Brees
and JJ Watt kept it yeah I know I'm
gonna keep it - all right take one
joining us on thank on behalf of Nu Old
Spice ultra smooth line design for guys
who want dermatologist-tested formulas
do you wear deodorant during again I was
locked in on this - its do you wear
deodorant during again yes
do you wear cologne during again no shot
okay if there's times people who don't
wear deodorant and you can like
especially like the big sweaty linemen
yeah and like when a tackle you can
might move just so they need some ultra
smooth for sure you can buy Old Spice
ultra smooth in stores now yep it's
great to see you thanks your daughter
doing she's doing fantastic actually
yeah lotsa goes on to an April Fool boy
okay they called terrible twos I know
she's already she she knows them she got
she got daddy on her boat already so was
it's it's a blessing I get to wake up
every day live my dream as a father and
live my dreams NFL player and hopefully
try to have impact on others one of
these days you can you can host this
show yeah when you think you're ready to
host this show do you think we have a
you can bring somebody out soon right
you're gonna win this season just
lockdown yeah so during that time I
already talked to my people I'm I jumped
yeah I get some time on on shows like
that just internship if I'm behind the
scenes just to learn more but that's
what you need you need to get around
people and see how you know you're
professional in one sport you got to be
professional in something else and so
you just have to figure that out but
don't be afraid to volunteer like you
spend a summer at the NFL Network and
work part-time it will help you and Mike
decide what you do you know in your
second career there's a
it's great to see a sake one thank you
again it's the new Old Spice ultra
smooth line say Quan Barclay of the
Giants we're back after this in the Dan
Patrick show for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]